Các bạn xong hủy như này, các cấp quý cơ quan các biểu phương
phải ra xác lại trên trên thực hiện lý quyết lại ở vốn của đàn
các nghĩ quyết của đàn và phón kiet hồi bị chung,
mà nhớ vụ cùng với một tiêu lối tượng đẹp bàn phải được tích hợp
nội dung trong chão phải được sự bý,
một lực và được điều phối thông ủy tư chung không để nhiều đồ mối cùng làm chung
nhưng không có cơ quan chữ trên nghiệp liệu.
Tân phân lại gió không việc, việc đã gió chủ trơn
đủ căn cứ vào được biệt về thực hiện nay,
việc cần thể chế ngoan phải xác bị cơ quan thời hạn và sản phẩm của thế.
Vì hợp mối, khó chữ có tiền lệ,
phải làm gó mối tắt, tầm buồn và vui thí điểm,
một lực cơ chỉ kiểm sát, không lấy lý gió chữ có tiền lệ để chế ngoan,
cũng không nó ngộ rí, rí, trí.
Thế chế ngoan phải kiếp thời đồng bộ chừng chủ trứng của đàn thành quy định
gió dàng khả thí, cấp nào có thầm quyền phải chủ đọc dạc quyết.
Vốn đẹp, vốn thầm quyền phải có ngay,
đồng thời để xuất phương an sửi không chỉ chuyện và mặt nguy tấp trên rồi mời trà đại.
Không đẹp khoảng trống phóc lý,
đứng dẫn thiếu thông nhất là mẹ chạp trễ không việc phát xin thêm tủ tộc
chí phi trong người dân cho ràng nhạc.
Về thống chính quyền điều phương hay cấp,
chúng tôi không đặc phương đẹp sắp sếp điều trình lại để giới hạn chính cấp sát,
vì cơ bản khả thống đang hạt động của lấy kiế hoa.
Tình thành phố nào, thấy thật sự cần kép,
trong tình dọ vụ.
Trong sống tháng, của năm 2020,
phần bảo vụ máy vẫn hành thông xuất,
sự lý điểm ngàn cấp bác.
Phần lấu khoảng thành thông nhất, một điều tình tế sau.
Trong nghiệm tì khoảng 18,
phải cơ bản thệ trễ ngoái,
tất quyết sách,
ngoàn thiện phân cấp phân quyền,
đạo nền tạng trong mùi phát triển mới,
vốn đến năm 2020,
năm 2020,
cũng trong buồn nhầm,
với nân cao năng lực tự trụ,
sức cạnh tranh của khả năng khi chấn
và sức trống trị của khoảng thệ.
Đừng được.